as india battles a devastating surge of
covet-19
infections and deaths a group of
scientists has come forward and said
warnings back in march of a new and more
dangerous variant
were ignored by the government hospitals
continue to be overwhelmed by the crisis
and india's vaccine rollout is being
hampered by a shortage of shots
people lie in the corridors of this
hospital in maja pradesh
those with a bed are hardly better off
without
oxygen relatives can only watch as their
loved ones
run out of breath
we haven't got any oxygen at all now
that's why i've put her in a prone
position
so that she can feel some relief i asked
the hospital but they can't give me any
because they don't have it either
precious oxygen is delivered to this
hospital in delhi
under police escort but it comes too
late
supplies ran out about an hour earlier
eight people
died waiting
we told them that we are doing the best
we can despite the lack of oxygen
and what was about to happen we begged
them to arrange oxygen from anywhere
they can
medical supplies are flying in from
germany ventilators
and from russia vaccines once a vaccine
exporter
india is now desperate for imports
several states have run out of vaccines
even as the inoculation campaign
expands to all adults
those who get a shot know they're among
the lucky ones
the situation is extremely grim i mean
of course that
is there aren't any words that can
explain the situation is extremely
extremely grim
the system is at a brink of collapse and
that's the reason why we try to get
vaccinated as early as possible
but these lines in punjab aren't for
vaccinations
sikh devotees are cramming together in a
shrine
religious gatherings have been partly
blamed for india's coronavirus outbreak
even prime minister narendra modi joined
the crowds
some indians blame his leadership for
the crisis
like this woman who lost her father you
know that there is a big failure
of judiciary of the nation of so many
people
who cheated me on cylinders wouldn't
give me facilities on time
and my father couldn't get anything on
time everything
god delayed everything
[Music]
across india anger burns like so many
funeral pyres
we're joined now by our correspondent
manira chowdhury in delhi
uh manira some heartbreaking scenes that
we just
saw there and meanwhile we're also
hearing reports that
a group of scientists in fact that
advise the indian government
warned that a new and more dangerous
virus variant
was discovered and this was back in
march
and yet the government ignored their
warnings apparently
what more can you tell us about this
well this is a forum of scientific
advisors which was set up in late
december
last year and yes they have come out and
said that they want
the government and the union health
ministry as early as early march that we
may be seeing
a peak in the number of cases we will
see an increase in the number of cases
and they also warned about a new
mutant virus which would be very very
contagious
much more than what we saw last year but
as they're coming out and saying that
the government did not pay heed to these
warnings
in fact the government did go ahead and
organize
massive election rallies in different
states where no covert protocols were
being followed
the government also allowed a huge
religious congregation to keep taking
place over a period of a couple of
months where hundreds and thousands of
people were gathering every single day
another scientist of the same forum has
said that the government has not taken
into account
signs and evidence while setting up
policies for dealing with the situation
has there been any response from india's
government
to these accusations that they ignored
these warnings
from their own scientific advisors i
mean what are they saying about this
well the government has not really come
forward and said anything yet
but then again the government has not
been responding to a lot of pertinent
questions that are being raised since
the second wave started
in fact what we are seeing is a
political blame game which has started
and reports also suggest that the
government had been in a very defensive
and dismissive mode
when faced with these questions and now
of course we know
that despite being the world's biggest
producer of vaccines
many states in india have had to stop
their vaccine roll up because they don't
have enough doses
how is vaccinations going right now
well as you would know we started we
expanded the vaccination campaign
yesterday to people above 18 years of
age but as reports suggest and in my
personal experience the people i've
spoken to
they're facing a lot of struggle in even
registering for the vaccination to the
government website and even getting a
slot for appointment to get their birth
jam
the center is saying that they are in
talks reportedly with the vaccine
manufacturers to
ramp up the production they are saying
that they are actually wrapping up the
production now
and that the government is also saying
they are providing states with a sizable
amount of
uh vaccine doses but the fact that
multiple states are coming forward as
saying that they have to put a hold on
this campaign because they do not have
enough number of doses
speaks volume of the current desperate
situation
dw's manira chaudary in delhi thank you
we appreciate your reporting
you